2011 dodge ram
um i got the new key in the old wind
we have the new wind module right here
we're going to install that
and go through the first thing we're
going to do is read the pin code
0 9 5 2 then we're going to pop the new
module
in there the win module and it's going
to come up as
all zeros and then we're going to
add the 0952 to the new one let me pop
that module in there i'll be right back
with you
all right we're back with dodge ram i
have two new keys
that one this one this does have remote
start
if it has two wires off the back you
have the plug
and the additional wire that is
a remote start vehicle with the
secondary i use these brand new oem from
mopar
um they program so much better you don't
have to deal with the drama
we pulled the security code 0952
we're gonna read this pin again out of
this it should show up as all zeroes
all zeros okay
module replacement pc
replacement wcm
event is correct
zero nine 5
2.
pin has been programmed
now it's going to transfer the
information
from the pcm to the wind module
i've been doing a bunch of these lately
a lot of these wind modules go bad
success cycle the key in the ignition
turn this off
turn this on
security's still blinking so now we're
going to go to program keys
back out of this program blank key
zero nine five two
okay
[Music]
keys programmed one
shut this off i can hit the buttons now
now this truck will run
they had a problem with the old wind
module where this guy would drive down
the road
he would hit a bump and the truck would
actually shut off
everything looks good program the other
key in now
[Music]
so
two keys are complete
key tip is good quick and easy way
change the wind i just have one screw
and holding it there for now i'm gonna
put the other screws in it
this module is obviously garbage and we
are done with this vehicle and put the
screws in and pop
everything back together thanks for
watching